hi my name's Edward mitula and I'm an
aspiring screenwriter so my script is
called Finn so I've been writing this
script now for five months and I've been
writing films as a total now for four
years and I think the reason I'm so
drawn to this film is because i am
writing what i know and i can genuinely
relate to the character and that's what
makes it more organic and more real
because before I was writing films about
like crime and things that I knew
nothing about so now that I'm writing
about something I know about and care
about it it feels real and I think that
links back to why I haven't given up on
it yet because Quinton doesn't get you
anywhere quitting is what separates
people are doing people are done and
more on that is that I'm actually
enjoying it why would I want to quit
something that I'm enjoying so much so
what do I really want for Finn I guess
all i want for Finn is for it to be made
into a real film I want it to be seen as
a real film I want it to be respected as
a real film and I want it to stand the
test of time I don't want it to be a
cash grab or anything like that because
there's no gimmick to it it needs to
stand the test of time because if you're
not making a film that's going to stand
the test of time what's the point in you
making the film for I attend college and
I also work part-time at film production
company which means a lot of my time is
taken up but I can always make time for
this because it's so important to me
it's the thing that I'm wanting to do
and the thing I'm thinking about while
I'm having to do with the things so it's
never a struggle being able to write so
i'll write whenever i have some time
free i will go and I will write or I'll
be always thinking of ideas and if I
don't think I've got enough done in one
day I'll then work into the night to
make sure i get enough hours done
there's never a day where I don't work
on the script so I have hours and hours
on it every day which is so so fun so my
own personal goal is to make it in the
film industry and to be a proper film
director to be able to make films that
matter and to be able to express myself
through film and most of all to do what
I love for a living
because this is all I want to do with my
life all I want to do is make films so
not being able to do that seems like
absolute hell so yeah that's all I want
to do I just want to make films so the
way I go into screen Ryan's pretty
interesting I always loved films and I
thought I'd try making some I'd watched
YouTube channels and stuff like that on
how to make film so I made a few short
films on my parents iPhones and they
were really bad but it was all learning
and I really enjoyed it I realized that
is what i wanted to do so after a while
of making films on a mobile phone I then
upgraded I wanted to set my own short
film production company called Bert I
productions and I set it up and I got a
grant of 5,000 pounds which I spent on
equipment and saying the company up and
since then I've made a whole bunch of
short films and the main thing is seeing
them improve over time is the real bit
where the addiction stems from where you
see how far you've come and you can only
think of how far you going to go it's
really really transfixing to sort of a
look at how it changes so I guess that's
how i got into screenwriting I then
wanted to start writing films and always
had ideas for full feature films and
then I wrote a few i wrote a few bad
ones at first which is given because
your first few scripts for a feature
film are going to be awful so i got
those out the way i wrote maybe three or
four of my first scripts and this script
now Finn is the script that I can see
actually becoming something and the one
that is worth putting the time into so
that's how i got into screenwriting and
that's how i got into making Finn so
thank you very much for watching but
also like to thank film courage because
their videos are so inspiring to be able
to watch people in the industry talk
about writing scripts it's such an
inspiring thing to do when you're
struggling to write sometimes or just to
get you up motivate to make a film so
yes massive thank you to film courage
for making those videos and allowing me
to make this video it's really cool that
you guys are doing this see ya thank you
very much for all your help